Kim Cattrall speaking of old Crazy Horse
she got into big trouble this week she
is building a new home in East Hampton
New York and apparently her neighbors
were upset at the construction noise so
an 80 year old man who was her neighbor
came over to the property to complain
about the noise the construction crew
was making she jumped out of her house
according to witnesses and began
screaming at the old man to get off her
property
imagine that old man being screamed at
to get off the lawn usually it's the
other way around police were called they
showed up and apparently there were no
arrests because he was in within his
rights the construction crew was making
a bunch of noise see if she was Samantha
he would have been on our lawn and she
would have just [ __ ] him exactly
everybody would have went happy I'm
assuming she heard the news that they
are going to make a Sex in the City
prequel movie that's why she's upset did
they announce that yeah so that means it
won't feature the ladies no because
apparently sex in the old folks home is
not an interesting title for that show I
love Sex in the City you could look at
me weird all you want I think it's a
really funny show it's basically the
girl version of everything that I was
doing in flicks they just sit around
talk about Falcon and sock in and
buckets a car alright alright but in any
event I love the show then I saw the
movie Ralph and felt a bit betrayed by
the movie because they know we all did
Kevin we all did they they made some of
the male characters act in a different
way I know I was so pissed off
especially with Carrie and big in that
whole time yes yes right I'm just
throwing [ __ ] out there I have no idea
he's making fun of me too yes
the second sequel though Ralph was
really really not good
didn't seem anything close to the
impossible I'm telling you it was just
it was like I threw one transformers but
you managed through to sex in the city
movies yeah what you're telling me
makes you learn about your partner when
you're on stage yeah but none of the
Transformers show their tits apparently
they are doing a prequel Sex in the City
prequel Candace Bushnell who wrote the
books yes has written several prequels
apparently to the other books that she
wrote so now that's where they're gonna
take off with either a TV show or a
feature film more than likely a feature
film they're talking about Charlotte the
role that was played by you tell me she
the brunette well she's the brunette one
anyone know Christine Davis yes
apparently they're talking about Selena
Gomez playing young Charlotte in the
movie she's a movie isn't that movie out
this weekend Monaco - Monte Carlo yeah a
Carlo and apparently Candace Bushnell
says that is her endorsement she said I
thought she was so pretty I was like
gosh wouldn't she be great as Charlotte
and I right or am I wrong the author
says she also said that she had heard
the rumor that Blake Lively was in talks
to take on the role of a young Carrie
Bradshaw which of course was played by
Jessica Sarah Jessica Parker I would
imagine most of what was special about
that show beyond the writing was the the
four leads I think if you replace him I
don't know I don't think it's like Star
Trek you know I get in yeah apparently
also up for the role of a young Carrie
Bradshaw is a three-year-old
thoroughbred mare called tumbleweed
comes from the Calumet Farms in
Lexington Kentucky apparently looking at
her to pray young Sarah Jessica Parker
Oh more cosmos please how many cosmos
would you like ma'am why three side of
apples
I love that you named it tumbleweed
[Music]
you
[Music]